fueron tres largas horas de lectura de
la resolución el juez Juan Carlos
checkley validó las acusaciones de la
fiscalía contra el expresidente Pedro
Castillo porque afirma que este cometió
los delitos de rebelión conspiración
abuso de autoridad delito contra la paz
pública por eso la corte peruana le
ordenó 18 meses de prisión preventiva el
juez también señaló que Pedro Castillo
luego de leer su mensaje donde ordena la
disolución del Congreso se dirigió a la
embajada de México y este eso constituye
un peligro de fuga y bloqueo al proceso
y también recordó que hora después
precisamente ese país habló sobre un
eventual asilo político contra el ex
mandatario esta corte le tocó otorgarle
mejor suerte al ex Primer Ministro
Aníbal Torres porque a él solamente se
le ordenó comparecencia con
restricciones y el pago de una pequeña
multa